[Music]
2019 is shaping up to be an incredible
year for horror films
here are some of the intriguing remakes
sequels to smash hits and awesome
original projects from beloved
filmmakers that are making their way to
horror fans
hereditary was easily one of the most
talked about horror films of 2018
its relentlessly slow building tension
and undeniably disturbing images
marked it as an assured debut from
writer director ariester
for his next film he'll be moving away
from the family homestead and taking a
show on the road
in midsummer we'll go along with a young
couple to a festival in rural sweden
laced with bad emotions that turns even
worse when they run afoul of a pagan
cult
is it scary astor describes it as quote
a dark breakup movie that becomes a
horror film and the trailer is
definitely intriguing
follow-ups to rapturously received first
efforts are always tricky to pull off
but we have a feeling that midsummer
will be a worthy follow-up to the
scariest film of 2018.
you are scary no i am not french
director alexander aja
established his horror bona fide to the
surprise 2003 hits high tension
and the 2006 remake of the classic the
hills have eyes
in 2019 he's back and teaming up with
producer sam raimi to bring us crawl
the film follows a young woman
desperately attempting to reach her
father during a category 5 hurricane
to make things worse she's trapped
inside a house which is slowly flooding
fortunately she's not alone she's got a
bunch of ravenous killer alligators
stopping by to keep her company the film
is being fast-tracked for a summer
release by paramount
which took a similar approach last year
with john krasinski's well received a
quiet place
if kroll's bonkers story and the film's
sterling pedigree are any indication
the studio could very well have another
gigantic hit on their hands
2016's the boy was an underrated little
thriller the story of a young american
woman named greta who was hired by an
eccentric english couple to care for
their porcelain dull brahms
greta learns from a local man that the
real brahms the couple's eight-year-old
son
was killed in a house fire decades prior
the odd situation is made even weirder
by the fact that the doll seems to have
a mind of its own and has a habit of
moving around the house when greta isn't
looking
at the conclusion it's revealed that the
real brahms has been alive the whole
time
living inside the walls of the house in
the upcoming brahms the boy 2
the man and his favorite play thing will
return for more atmospheric chills the
sequel will see a couple move into
braum's abode with their young son and
this time around the supernatural
angle may not be a fake out the boys
team of director william brent bell and
writer stacey mania will return
we'll see if braums can separate himself
from the creepy doll pack when the movie
hits screens on july 26th
the 80s and 90s were a great time for
children's horror literature
and if the goosebumps series wasn't
quite freaky enough there was always
scary stories to tell in the dark the
short story collections by alvin
schwartz
initially featured the singularly
bizarre illustrations of steven gamel
which was such pure nightmare fuel for
readers they were infamously replaced
with toned down versions
for later additions eml del toro has
long been working on adapting the
property for the screen
and this year we'll finally get to see
the fruits of his labor
produced and co-written by del toro the
feature will focus on a group of young
teens who must solve the mysterious
deaths in their small town
sarah bellows his book where the stories
write themselves and it all comes alive
and the director's chair is andre
ofredol who's features trollhunter and
the autopsy of jane doe marked him as a
talent to watch with that level of
pedigree the long gestating production
looks like a worthy companion for those
horrifying drawings that used to keep so
many of us up at night
it's been rumored for years and it's
finally happening just in time for the
10th anniversary of the original
zombieland zombieland doubletap is on
the way to deliver more blood-soaked
comedic madness
the whole band is getting back together
for the long-awaited sequel
including director reuben fleischer and
writers rhett reese and paul wernick
in addition the entirety of the original
cast is back on board
including woody harrelson emma stone
abigail breslin
and jesse eisenberg this is good
the first official synopsis hints at new
kinds of zombies as well as a possible
human threat
either way there doesn't seem to be much
reinventing of the wheel here which
should suit fans of the first film just
fine
they've been clamoring for a return to
zombieland for years and they're finally
getting it
just don't forget the rules and why am i
alive when everyone around me has turned
to meat
it's because of my list of rules rule
number one for surviving zombieland
cardio those of us who grew up on the
kids tv network nickelodeon have fond if
sometimes uncomfortable memories of the
horror anthology series
are you afraid of the dark the show
featured a group of teens calling
themselves the midnight society
who regularly gathered around a campfire
in a secret place to tell scary stories
despite the kid-friendly concept more
than a few episodes were surprisingly
horrifying
the forthcoming film adaptation will be
leading into the show's darker elements
courtesy of co-writer gary dobberman
best known for his writing on it and the
none
dorbaman has said he wants to keep the
deeply scary and dark aspects of the
original series alive in the film he
elaborated that while the film will
still feature the midnight society and
the campfire setting
he won't be adapting any episodes but
will tell a completely original story
director dj caruso best known for triple
x return of xander cage will helm the
film
which drops just in time for halloween
despite the character's apparent deaths
at the conclusion of 2005's of devil's
rejects
fans of rob zombie have been piling for
the return of mass murderers otis baby
and captain spalding ever since
it took over a dozen years but in 2018
zombie confirmed that he'd be bringing
the murderous trio back in three from
hell concluding this series he started
with house of a thousand corpses in
2003.
the film was wrapped shooting and zombie
has been screening a teaser trailer for
fans at his shows grainy images of which
have found their way online in a year
rife with long-awaited horror sequels
3 from hell maybe the longest awaited of
them all he is hoping zombie helps a
disturbing gory auntie in that special
way only he can
[Music]
pretty much every horror fan alive has
some degree of reverence for stanley
kubrick's 1980 stephen king adaptation
the shining
even if king himself was not
particularly impressed king's novel was
a highly personal project for him which
is probably one reason he chose to
revisit the character of danny torrance
in 2013 with dr sleep
with the king cinematic renaissance in
full swing it seemed like only a matter
of time before the book would get the
big screen treatment
late this year it's finally happening at
the helm is mike flanagan who directed
the well-received king adaptation
gerald's game
and or 10 episodes of the haunting of
hill house for netflix king had great
things to say about flanagan's work on
gerald's game
hopefully the director will turn in an
adaptation a bit more to king's liking
than the famously eccentric kubrick was
able to
1997 spawn is mostly known for sporting
some of the most ridiculous
cgi 1997 had to offer but the character
has always been a compelling one
created by comic artist todd mcfarlane
al simmons is a former cia mercenary
whose soul is sent to hell upon his
death as punishment for his earthly
misdeeds
but he's resurrected as a demonic
anti-hero spawn in order to atone for
his misdeeds by wreaking terrible
vengeance
on the criminal underworld in light of
the 1997 film's failure mcfarland
himself will be rebooting the character
for a new audience
he'll write the script and also make his
feature debut as a director
mcfarlane has had a vision for what the
film would be for a long time in a talk
with collider in 2017
macfarlane laid out what the film would
be like and it's going to be a dark
edgy supernatural scary messed up movie
jamie foxx in the total role and jason
blum producing
spawn will begin shooting in 2019 for a
likely release later in the year
legendary director david cronenberg's
status as a master of body horror was
firmly cemented with his 1977 feature
rabbid
the film follows adult film icon marilyn
chambers as a young woman who undergoes
a hideous transformation
after an experimental surgery saves her
life following a motorcycle accident
cronenberg's singular visions don't
exactly lend themselves to the reboot
treatment but if you're familiar with
the work of jen and sylvia sorska
also known as the twisted twins you
won't be surprised that they were
willing to give it a shot
with features like 2009's dead hooker in
a trunk and 2012's deeply strange
american mary under their belts they'll
be taking on an updated version of rabid
for 2019
one which promises to at least try to
outweird cronenberg's original while it
will feature a few modern twists the
sauce girls will be leading into the
gory and settling heart of the 1977 film
a task for which they seem uniquely
suited they promise that their version
will be modernized through a female
perspective
and will honor not only the original but
cronenberg's entire body of work
apparently mastery of horror runs on the
family joe hill the son of the legendary
stephen king has made a name for himself
as a successful horror writer in his own
right
with novels like horns and norse ferrari
both of which have been adapted for film
and television respectively among hill's
formidable bibliography are a couple
collaborations with his dad one of the
short stories that resulted from their
collaboration and the tall grass is
headed to the small screen
this year as a netflix original film the
story follows a pair of siblings whose
cross-country trip
takes a turn for the weird when they
hear the cries of a young boy emanating
from a field
very quickly they find out that it's
easy to get lost writer director
vincenzo nattorli
is best known for directing the minor
horror classic cube and has also
recently handled episodes of luke cage
and westworld
adding a touch of horror pedigree is
patrick wilson star of the conjuring
films with a team like that
in the tall grass might just end up
being another bird box type hit for
netflix
2016's don't breathe the sophomore
feature from director feddy alvarez was
a claustrophobic nightmare of the first
order
it told the story of a trio of hoodlums
who planned to loot the house of a blind
war veteran
for the cash he's supposedly hoarding
only to find the old guy to be much more
capable and sadistic than they were
ready for
veteran character actor stephen lang was
absolutely terrifying in his role
and even though the film's conclusion
didn't exactly seem to be setting up a
sequel
don't breathe too is on the way the
movie has been in the works for some
time
in late 2016 alvarez's producing partner
sam raimi called its concept the
greatest idea for a sequel
he's ever heard while alvarez teased an
arctic approach to the second
installment
plot casting and production details are
being kept tightly under wraps
but it's a safe bet that we'll see don't
breathe too in time for halloween
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one